[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the most
vile of the dark aunts known to the
wizarding world of harry potter
horcruxes
for any witch or wizard making a horcrux
is considered to be the worst kind of
magic
in fact it is a brand of dark arts that
is thought to be so evil and revolting
that it is intentionally never discussed
and information on how to create one is
very limited for this reason many
witches and wizards don't even know what
creating a horcrux involves and as it
turns out neither do we
but here's what we do know
the very first horcrux was made in
ancient greece by a wizard named herper
the fowl and thousands of years later
voldemort became only the second known
creator of the hawk rugs
made from magic that is so terrible in
nature that even dark wizards are
horrified by what it entails
horcruxes are creations that are
unimaginable to the vast majority of the
wizarding world
so when voldemort made seven it was a
demonstration of just how incredibly
evil he was to make a horcrux a damaged
piece of one soul must be removed from
the creator's body
and put into an inanimate object or
living host making the creator immortal
in order to do this the witch or wizard
who wishes to split their soul needs to
commit the ultimate act of violence and
evil
murder
and not just any murder they have to
deliberately kill someone without regret
or remorse
acting in self-defense or retaliating in
protection of someone else will not
result in the ability to create a
horcrux it must be done with the utmost
evil intent resulting in a metaphysical
damaging of the murderer's soul it's
important to note that this
fragmentation of the soul would occur
after a murder of this sort regardless
of whether or not the witch or wizard
intended to create a horcrux
it's just that one who wishes to make a
horcrux then uses the damaging of their
soul to their advantage
in any case after they have killed their
victim the witch or wizard uses a
powerful incantation
to remove this damaged part of their
soul from their body
placing it in a vessel outside of
themselves and then performing an
unknown ritual to bound the fragmented
soul
to its new container
so what exactly happens during this
disturbing ceremony from interviews that
jk rowling has given over the years she
has said that what she imagined as the
ritual for creating a horcrux is so vile
that she doesn't even want to say it out
loud
this of course is the narrative in the
harry potter universe as well
creating a horcrux is so dark in nature
that limited knowledge of the practice
is known within the wider wizarding
community
and albus dumbledore forbade the
instruction and the study of horcruxes
at hogwarts while he was head master of
the school even books in the restricted
section of hogwarts library
barely acknowledge horcruxes existence
the only known book to detail the
creation repercussions and destruction
of horcrux is a text called secrets of
the darkest art at one point this exact
book was kept in the restricted section
however after dumbledore realized the
depth of detail it provided on how to
make a horcrux he removed it from the
library and kept it hidden in his
headmaster's office unfortunately he did
so only after tom riddle had found and
read it
which still leaves us asking what
happens during this ritual from the
theories that i've heard on the internet
here are a couple that i feel are most
plausible
the murderer must eat part of their
victim
in other words the unknown ritual is
cannibalism there's lots of good support
around this theory including the sheer
fact that cannibalism is revolting
but for another thing cannibalism is
present in many literary works through
the ages and rowling has been known to
find inspiration in classical literature
of course there's the issue that none of
voldemort's victims who are linked to
the creation of his horcruxes had
anything notably missing from their
bodies
although as powerful as he was it's not
out of the question that he was able to
feed off of the insides of these victims
without leaving any noticeable marks
another theory is that voldemort had to
give up pieces of his own body
in order to bind his soul to each
container this could account for how his
looks deteriorated as he gained more
power and created additional horcruxes
his nose became non-existent his eyes
became red slits perhaps these were the
body parts he exchanged for immortality
of course these changes could also be
attributed to his crumbling humanity as
he continued to rip his soul apart
so other than just being an evil witch
or wizard why go through this horrifying
ordeal
well if the container of a fragment and
soul remains intact the soul stays
within the realm of the living for all
eternity
keeping its creator alive
even if their body was destroyed
this is how voldemort survived after his
body was reduced to nothing when he
attempted to murder an infant harry
potter and as we saw voldemort
accomplish later in the series
since his fragments of soul remained in
various horcruxes he was able to
eventually regain a physical body
even though his original form had been
destroyed however there is also the
stability of the soul to consider
once a soul is split it becomes
incredibly unstable
so you can imagine just how out of
control voldemort's soul would have been
after splitting seven times
which is why as dumbledore shared with
harry it simply broke apart when he
attempted to kill harry while it was
originally thought that a witch or
wizard could only split their soul in
half voldemort managed to sever his six
additional times
although the seventh time with harry was
unintentional it would seem that equal
sized pieces are fragmented with the
creation of each horcrux and considering
how unstable the main part of
voldemort's soul became it's clear that
even though one could create more than a
single horcrux
there is a finite number of times one
can rip their soul apart in addition to
the magic used to create a hawk rucks
counter charms and curses were often put
upon them in order to protect the piece
of soul inside
this would look different depending on
the type of spell used by the creator
for example the aggressive behavior of
some of voldemort's horcruxes was likely
due to enhanced magic that the dark lord
chose to bewitch them with this can be
seen in how tom riddles diary wanted to
possess ginny weasley's body and how
salazar sathering's locket gave its
wearer poisonous thoughts and visions to
corrupt their thinking and drive them
mad there was also the cursed ring of
marvolo gaunt that would have eventually
killed albus dumbledore had he not been
cursed to death by snape it's also
interesting that the pieces of a soul
found in the horcrux directly reflects
the crater at the time in which the
horcrux was made
like tom riddle in the diary
it's voldemort soul from when he was 16
and made this first horcrux after
murdering myrtle warren the piece of
soul is unable to grow or age it's more
like a snapshot of their soul at the
time it was created this seems to differ
from when a horcrux is made out of a
living object
can the peace of soul talk to the host
does it ever take over the host based on
harry's experience as an accidental
horcrux it would seem that the peace of
the soul co-exists in the shadows of
one's mind
but can surface in certain ways for
example harry has his scar which would
sear in pain
and this seemed to be directly linked to
voldemort's emotions
he also had voldemort's ability to speak
parcel tongue
and at times was able to see into
voldemort's mind
side effects of creating a horcrux
include dehumanization an unstable soul
and the inability to find peace in death
as seen by the maimed creature that
harry encounters in limbo after he's
been killed in the deathly hallows this
brings us to the destruction of
horcruxes
there are a few ways to destroy these
pieces of dark magic
one of which could also reunite the soul
and potentially cure the side effects
just mentioned in this instance the
kratom has to feel such remorse as to
bring his soul back together
apparently this process is incredibly
painful
and for witches and wizards who have
fragmented their soul in this way
an unlikely path
other options to eliminate a horcrux
both living and inanimate includes
basilisk venom fiend fire and anything
that has absorbed an element capable of
destroying a horcrux such as basilisk
venom throughout the series we see
basilisk venom destroy two horcruxes
tom riddle's diary and helga
hufflepuff's cup
fire takes out rowena ravenclaw's diadem
and the sword of gryffindor which harry
used to defeat the basilisk in the
chamber of secrets thereby absorbing its
venom eliminates salazar sutherland's
locket marvolo gaunt's ring and nagini
it would seem based on the fact that
being hit with the killing curse removed
voldemort's soul from harry that dying
could remove a horcrux from a living
host although it's unclear if avada
kadavra could have taken down nagini or
if her death had to come from one of the
listed weapons above
that is basilisk venom fiend fire or
souped up goblin made steel although
harry was bitten by the basilisk in the
chamber of secrets so it stands to
reason that the horcrux in him could
have or maybe even should have been
affected
but since harry was saved by phoenix
tears and didn't die
it would seem that it remained fully
untouched i'm curious though if harry
had died by basilisk venom would
voldemort's horcrux inside of him have
been destroyed
and could he have come back in the same
way he did in the deathly hallows sans
horcrux i guess we'll never know
what do you think do you have any
theories on the third mysterious step of
creating a horcrux let me know your
thoughts in the comments below
and as always if you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember
to the well-organized mind death is but
the next great adventure
you